hey what's up everybody its Warren and
we finally have confirmation for a Loki
theory that has been around for a very
very long time
it's been around since the very first
Avengers film so quite a while it's a
theory involving Loki in the mine stone
in the very first Avengers film and if
you're not familiar with a theory don't
worry I'll briefly explain it but just a
reminder there are only three days left
in my Infinity Gauntlet giveaway I will
be picking a winner on New Year's Day so
if you would like to enter for your
chance to win an Infinity Gauntlet all
you have to do is subscribe to my
channel like this video and comment down
below with your thoughts and your
favorite superhero so again this theory
has been around for a while since the
very first Avengers movie in 2012 it's a
pretty simple theory but it makes a lot
of sense and it states that Loki's mind
was actually being controlled the whole
entire movie
Thanos gave Loki the sceptre which
contained the mine stone so the theory
stated that the sceptre could not only
take over the person's mind but also
influence what they do something that
Loki wouldn't have realized what's
happening so this makes him more of a
victim than a villain so that's the
theory and again it's pretty simple but
it makes a lot of sense
so after years and years of this theory
being out there we finally have
confirmation from Marvel themself if you
go to Marvel's official character page
for Loki you'll notice that it's been
changed and you'll also notice that it
now confirms the mine stone Loki theory
it talks about the end of the first Thor
movie where Loki falls into the abyss it
then reads arriving at the sanctuary
through a wormhole caused by the Bifrost
Loki met the other ruler of the ancient
race of extraterrestrials that cheat re
and Fanus offering the god of mischief
dominion over his brother's favorite
realm earth
Thanos requested the tesseract in return
gifted with a scepter that acted as a
mind-control device Loki would be able
to influence others unbeknownst to him
the scepter was also influencing him
fueling his hatred over his brother Thor
and the inhabitants of Earth so there
you have it Marvel has just confirmed
that the mind stone was in fact
influencing Loki throughout the events
of the first Avengers film it's
important to note that although Loki's
behavior has been
devious and troublesome in the MCU he
always thought that he had good
intentions it even says this on the
Marvel character page for Loki when
talking about Loki going into the black
hole it says devastated that the
all-father could not see his actions
were for him and Asgard
Loki lets go and falls into the abyss
and although he would continue to cause
trouble in the MCU we do see him be good
sometimes we see him help Thor in Thor
the dark world thor ragnarok and of
course an Avengers infinity war so even
though Loki has always kind of hated
Thor and humans it has never been taken
to an extreme like it was in the first
Avengers film most of the time not all
the time but most of the time he can put
his hatred aside for the greater good
and that's what we see in the dark world
Ragnarok and infinity war but he was not
able to do that in the first Avengers
film because the mind son was
influencing him and fueling his hatred
so this confirms the theory that Loki
was actually being manipulated by the
mind stone in the first Avengers movie
let me know what you all think about
this and let me know if you think we'll
see Loki and Avengers endgame let me
know your thoughts in the comments down
below and again don't forget to
subscribe to my channel like this video
and comment down below with your
thoughts and your favorite superhero so
you can enter the Infinity Gauntlet
giveaway and stay up to date on
everything relating to Avengers endgame
as always thank you all so much for
watching
Wolf Wolf
[Music]